oh my wife's Mexican okay aren't you no
I'm not mad we've already gone through
this you know this your wife I have two
Mexican children damn she be whooping
your ass in there huh
[__] your ass up she be on the
croissant [__] in there
man no no
no no [__] call yourself
she definitely I don't know Christian
[__] oh my God it's funny because that
[__] is real because they came here like
two weeks ago that's just real real and
she carved her [__] their initials
into the table right there oh that's
crazy oh she's like this like pissed and
like I'm like what
[__] it it's survive property damage but
like an hour prior to them getting here
like well they were here an hour prior
to the interview starting they were just
yelling at each other while he was
getting his hair cut in the other
building I'm sorry Kev that's probably
something that's probably the best
vagina on this planet to continue to
deal with that I don't even think bro
I'm gonna be honest let me give you some
head [__] people like oh my God look at
everything I'm gonna be I think I think
that wipe it away I think being being
near them for a couple of hours it made
me kind of realize like well now that
she's sober it feels a little like I
don't know man it feels a little
manipulative on the blue face side I
feel like he's kind of running up the
numbers right now because he kind of
knows like let's go viral no no I said
it in the interview I'm like yo she's
more popping than you he's like yeah she
signed to me I want her to be more
popular
whoa oh so he's running it up I think
that's more of what's happening so it's
not real no it is real but I mean she's
pregnant God I mean it's a sad situation
I think that whole thing like it's like
kind of what is it worth it the numbers
the money but yeah some of the no jumper
[__] that happened like I definitely
would not name something
talk about it
um I mean the firing thing you know I
think um
I just think that like I was telling
that in the same [__] like lie to me
Lush no sometimes
um just some of the like I feel like uh
we would talk about like it felt like
sometimes he would just be having random
gang members on that don't really ain't
doing [__] but are gang members I don't
know yeah there was like a little like
point in time it was an error there was
like an era like the [__] Mack era where
it felt like every other guy on the show
was fascinated with street closer and it
was like uh so-and-so on being a
something something [__] and going to
jail and being white yeah
like no substance there
I mean but what the [__] are you
supposed to do when no artist gonna come
through there you know what I'm saying
it works right like yes like like to me
like I can't even fall like to me the
the no jumper thing has worked it is way
bigger than what I'm doing but you know
for for me like just a lot of the like
uh the [__] that happened with house
phone you know I think was was uh
terrible it was mishandled flagrantly
even even if it wasn't meant to be
misandle flake really like
like I was telling him I was like bro
that that wouldn't even that wasn't even
the sniff the YouTube that wouldn't even
got
you can't even load that up and that's
and that's where accountability goes
into play right